Mort cursed Kellogg was a compulsive
Gambler known for having very bad luck
prior to enlisting of which he did in
order to pay back the money that he owed
now as a third target of the season 11
Manhunt kirst's unlucky streak continues
he has been found on the streets of DC
and division agents are closing in
[Music]
Mort cursed Kellogg's life took a turn
for the worse when he developed a
serious gambling problem he found
himself in debt to Loan Sharks before he
even graduated from high school and the
debts only grew larger as time went on
eventually he realized that he needed to
do something drastic to get out of debt
and avoid his collectors so we enlisted
in the army
he was deployed to the dagger complex in
darmstadt Germany where he quickly
became known for his logistical
expertise he had a natural talent for
managing suppliers and his superiors
took notice however cursed was never
able to shake his gambling habit even in
Germany he continued to gamble on Sports
and other events often putting himself
further into debt
when the green poison was released
Hearst was on a weekend trip to
Copenhagen in Malmo where he bought a
Euro jackpot lottery ticket he played
his lucky numbers and forgot about the
ticket and told the drawing the
following Friday to his amazement all of
his numbers came up but his excitement
was short-lived as he learned about the
viral outbreak that was rapidly
spreading across the globe
cursed's luck seemed to have run out but
fate had other plans
he would eventually join the Black Tusk
and become one of the highest ranking
Logistics officers
his expertise in managing supplies and
resources made him invaluable to the
organization and he quickly Rose through
the ranks
his gambling habit may have put him in
debt but it also gave him a natural
talent for taking calculated risks
something that would serve him well in
this new position
as a member of the Black Tusk first was
instrumental in many of their operations
using his expertise to help the
organization acquire the resources they
needed to accomplish their goals
despite his past he had become a
respected and trusted member of the
group and his loyalty to the cause was
never in question
um you want me to reach out to Bantam or
Kaplan plane Phantom seems nervous
huh
affected they did
looks like they weren't as loyal to
Anderson as he thought the trouble with
following a charismatic leader when you
lose the leader you lose your following
agreed best part of working for a
faceless organization you're behold to a
power structure not a narcissist
I can't tell if you're being sarcastic
no sarcasm
signed on for the big
pick and security
you know me so well I do
and that's why I think you're the right
person to reach out to Kaplan we need to
weed out potential traders in our midst
you worry she's a traitor no
I think she's got the right access
psychology and skill set to spot them
Natalia is looking for any more
potential traitors within the true Sons
it believes Kaplan could be the one to
find them viscon's piece also shows the
sort of loyalty host has with Natalya
and the Black Tusk
Court is it going to be a problem I
don't think so
he's too afraid of me to betray me I
don't know how anyone can be afraid of
you that's because you've never been on
the receiving end of my wrath cursed
that's true you have saved my life on
more than one occasion have you found
anything only thing a note I've seen
some specialized medical equipment going
in and out of the White House could be
for Schaefer could be nothing no way to
tell without infiltrating the White
House that's a suicide mission stick to
Recon for now
confirmation that someone's in a coma
but you can't confirm it is Schaefer
that's unfortunately correct of course
we apprehended one of the cooks and how
does that confirm a coma patient they
were instructed to make meals for tube
feeding and maintain feed line
sanitation but they never installed the
line or saw the patient
correct said that there was restricted
access to
his room who has clearance
[Applause]
Kelso
friend captain Louis wow he sure fell
into favor quickly is there an
opportunity there perhaps
he's been turned before
men like that aren't the most loyal
[Music]
Captain Lewis has shifted loyalties
twice in the past we abandoned the jtf
of true sons and then once again more
recently when he teamed up with the
division Natalia sees this as a
potential opportunity
they still haven't confirmed that
Schaefer is in there but they're
certainly getting close
it's seeming more and more likely that
if this attack on the White House does
happen that Schaefer is going to be the
reason for it Natalia knows that he has
too much Intel to give if he was to ever
wake up
are you worried about radiation
you've been talking to chunks haven't
you no stove pain just take your iodine
and calm down you don't think the rumors
are true about St Louis yeah I think
anytime people tell you a rumor is just
a rumor they're trying to cover
something up so yeah I think the rumors
are true
[__] don't worry about St Louis worry
about Fairview why
you've seen the way they handled the
nuclear waste no no no they would have
told us
brother I think your helmet's on too
tight
I'm still not sure how the events in St
Louis will tie into the story yet I
don't see us heading over there but
maybe it'll have something to do with
the future conflicts against the
outcasts
however what I find more interesting is
the reference to Fairview power plunge
not just from cursed but also from Wally
right after receiving these comms
ever since we lost major Castillo that
place has gone to [__] I get why you had
to take him out that man's grief drove
him to some really dark places
when Majors Castillo was taken out it
wasn't really anyone to look after the
plant yes he trained a few of the true
Sons to keep things running but this was
never going to be adequate in the long
term
Phantom's training is a nuke more than
justifies his concerns however he's now
gone too
Natalia was a smart lady Julie she is
aware of what's Happening Here and what
is she planning
forget dc-62 or even the green poison
radiation and dirty bombs could soon be
the problem and as far as I'm aware I
don't think the division has anyone
qualified to fix it so you can't exactly
storm the area
as the division agents received Intel on
what cursed's Kellogg's whereabouts they
quickly mobilized and headed towards
Constitution Hall where the black task
was conducting their operations the team
had to move cautiously and strategically
taking down various outposts one by one
throughout the district to ensure their
cover wasn't blown
once they cleared the outposts the
agents discovered the cursed had moved
to Tidal Basin a heavily Fortified Area
controlled by the Black Tusk
team had their work cut out for them but
they were determined to take down the
enemy and put an end to their plans
they encountered Fierce resistance as
they made their way through the area but
their extensive training in Superior
Equipment proved to be too much
eventually cursed would make his
presence known and approached the agents
exceptionally slowly
at this point it's hard not to feel
sorry for Mort curse Kellogg not only
did he have a gambling addiction that
would eventually result in him being
placed into this very position the
agents are facing right now but he would
also be trolled by the Black Tusk who
would put him in the hilariously clunky
armor with a belt-fit minigun that the
agents were more than familiar with by
now
after clearing his Entourage the agent
spent a little bit of time playing with
their prey until they eventually decided
to show him how it was done by pulling
out their own minigun and Blasting holes
straight through his armor
foreign
ification confirmed Lord cursed Kellogg
status deceased
yet again more questions than answers
but a couple more weeks and we'll have
the fourth Target in the final Manhunt
so with that we should see if some of
these theories will play out
this video took me a while to put out
because the final mission kept bugging
out on me so I had to play through the
full Manhunt including the true previous
targets three times before I could get
it to work but um oh well we got there
eventually
that's about it for this video but
before I go I mentioned in my last video
that I would start to point out some of
the smaller division creators who I
think are criminally underrated and the
first one I would like to mention is ski
potato sorry dude I'm probably saying
that wrong
[Music]
and this is obviously the best
all directives open world build in the
world
behold best friend
is from Finland and his videos are
hilarious I didn't know build videos
could be their entertaining to watch I
didn't care much for the builds I mean
I'm sure they're great but that wasn't
the reason I kept watching through his
videos
the other thing I'm really impressed
with is the work that he puts into the
editing every video I watch makes me
want to step up my production value
so if you're interested please check him
out tell him I sent you I'll have a link
to his channel on the screen in the top
right hand corner and also in the
description
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one stream of
smallest extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]